hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and I'm a property investor I've been
buying houses for the last 12 years
normally when the house sucks and it
needs a lot of work you can just tell by
walking in it it's just obvious
sometimes there are problems with
properties that are not that obvious to
the naked eye over the last 12 years of
buying properties I mean I'm not an
expert when it comes to building and
structures and surveys but I am an
expert when it comes to investing in
property so I'm going to give you the
Layman's version the things that you
need to look out for when buying
properties the things that people try
and cover up but literally the house can
be completely unmortgageable if it has
one of these problems so these are the
top 10 number one is damp now damp isn't
necessarily an absolute deal breaker but
if there's if there's severe damp
problems in the property it can cost
thousands and thousands and thousands of
pounds to fix and sometimes the current
owners can just paint over the damp and
you look at it and it looks great you're
in a room like this and you think this
looks really nice but really it's not
how do you know no well you just smell
and if it smells a bit damp just a bit
musty there's a chance there might be
damp there now you can still see as well
if the walls just look a little bit wet
you're thinking ah you know that could
be damp as well so make sure that you do
get a survey on the property to check
for damp before you buy it especially if
you suspect that there could be damp
number two is structural problems if the
house feels a little bit Rocky sometimes
you almost it feels like you're in a
boat I've been in houses that are so at
the subsidence is so bad the house is
sinking the the floors are uneven now it
might be historical subsidence which
isn't necessarily a deal breaker because
it's it's it's historical it's not going
to get any worse but again be very very
careful if the house feels a bit wonky
or if there's cracks in the walls now if
there's a crack in the wall but the wall
is a plasterboard wall knock on the wall
and if it has a hollow sound and it's
just plasterboard it's not really a big
deal but if the wall is a brick wall and
there's a crack what you want to do is
you want to look on the outside of the
building and if the crack goes right the
way through that means that you have a
structural problem the whole property
might be unmortgageable something you
need to really really watch for when
buying a property number three is
non-standard construction now if the
house is built with bricks bricks are
pretty safe lenders and mortgage
companies if it's a brick built house
which most houses are sometimes they'll
render over the bricks so it doesn't
look like it's been made out of bricks
it just looks rendered but if it's Brick
House usually pretty safe if the house
has been built with non-standard
construction so it's a Concrete house or
it's something a little bit different it
might mean that the house is not as
secure it's not as safe and lenders are
very very skeptical of that I've met
people some of my students even have
said to me oh my gosh all the houses in
the street are selling for a hundred
thousand pounds I've managed to get mine
for 80 thousand pounds but it's because
all the houses in the street are brick
but theirs is of non-standard
construction and that's why it's so
cheap so watch out for that that can
also be completely unmortgageable number
four is has there been an extension on
the property that you're buying maybe a
conservatory maybe there's a um an attic
conversion which is now a bedroom that's
not a problem but has there been
planning permission on that extension if
not it might be that the extension or
the conversion was done illegally and
it's gonna you might have to you might
buy the house and then you inherit the
problem and then you could have to
literally strip out the attic conversion
you could have to knock down the
extension I mean it can get pretty rough
so if there's any new extensions or
conversions to them in the house ask to
see for planning permission a little tip
I'll give you is if there isn't um if
there is a room that's been built
recently or been converted recently and
the house is being sold the estate agent
will refer to it as something like space
or they'll called the bedroom upstairs
attic space that means that the bedroom
is probably not got planning permission
so that's something you need to be
really really careful of before buying a
property number five is just general
unusual legality problems so things like
a flying lease hold issue
um a ransom strip in the garden a
restrictive covenant on the property
that might prohibit you from doing
things that you might want to do like
have an office in the property or rent
the property out so this is something
that you need to be really careful of
and what I would suggest is just have a
solicitor that speaks plain English and
always when you're buying a property
they have a good dialogue with your
solicitor and make sure that they tell
you there's any red flags as far as the
legalities are concerned also be really
upfront from the very beginning with
your solicitor and with the agent and
with everybody and your mortgage brokers
about what the purpose of the use is of
the property number six you need to
watch out for dodgy electrics rewiring a
house in other words getting new
electric across the house can be very
expensive it might cost around about
five thousand pounds if the electrics
are completely shot and how you check
free electrics there's different things
you can do you can look at the fuse box
if the fuse box is an old style fuse box
it will look like this then that
probably means that the electrics might
need changing pretty soon the fuse box
should look more like this this is a new
fuse box most fuse boxes look like this
and it gives you an idea that it's safe
second thing is to check when the
electrics were last serviced I would
suggest they should be serviced in the
last five years sometimes you'll be
buying a house the electrics haven't
been serviced or looked up for 12 15
years you are going to need to look at
the electrics and spend some money which
is going to come out of your profit
third thing as well with the electrics
is are the lights on are there any
really obvious red flags I went to one
property and it looked okay the property
was in great condition but there was
wires hanging from the ceiling with
little bits of sellotape attached onto
them massive red flower bag and it
turned out that it needed a complete
rewire which was going to cost 4 000
pounds so dodgy electrics is always
something that you need to look out for
and you don't need to be a super
electrician to be able to spot the red
flags number seven thing you need to
watch out for this is something that
most people don't look at they look at
the kitchen and the bathroom and they
never look at this but this is one of
the things that can be very costly if
you buy it and it's broken and that is
the roof needing a roof to be fixed
again is going to be in the thousands of
pounds and how do you check whether the
roof is broken how do you check whether
the roof needs fixing or not and the
answer is to take a step back from the
house and look at it if there are
obvious missing tiles and cracks and
things aren't in alignment you're
probably going to need to spend some
money on the roof maybe potentially get
the whole roof redone the roof should
look neat it should look tidy make sure
that it doesn't bow again if it bows and
it looks a bit sloppy uh or droopy then
you might need to spend money on the
roof any issues with this if you have
any concerns at all get a professional
in to come out and look at it and give
you a quote before you buy the house
number eight is check for mine shafts
and high risk flooding areas now mine
shafts under the property will
potentially make the property
unmortgageable it will also
significantly reduce the resale value of
the property so how do you find out if
there's a mine shaft under the property
if the estate agent knows they are
obliged to tell you up front and it
should be on the description on
Rightmove or whatever the property is
being sold you can also check for this
online it doesn't cost very much at all
I think it's around about 30 pounds and
you can check there's a mine shaft under
the property also you can check the area
is it a high risk flooding area again
although that might not affect the cost
of the property the insurance is going
to be significantly higher if there is a
high flooding risk so check these things
these are things that also can catch
people out when you're just starting out
number nine and this is a really obvious
one but if the property is leasehold
make sure that the lease is very long on
the property so the difference between
Freehold and Lease sold if it's Freehold
you buy the house and you're also buying
the land if you're buying a leasehold
property you're buying the house but
you're not buying the land now that's
not necessarily terrible if you're
buying the house and the land is you've
got a lease on it for say a hundred
years but if there's a short lease on
the property that could really Scupper
you because when it comes when the lease
runs out then you're left at the mercy
of the Freeholder who owns the land and
they could then charge you an absolutely
ridiculous rent and force you to have to
make some drastic changes and also the
value of the property could almost
become zero so just make sure when
you're buying a property there's a long
lease on it if it's Freehold then
brilliant if the lease is short make
sure that you find out how much it's
going to cost to renew the lease before
you buy the property really really
important a lot of newbies that are
starting out think oh my gosh this house
is so cheap but what they don't realize
is it's leasehold the lease isn't
particularly long on the property so
this will always if you're buying a
property online on Rightmove it will
always be on the description but also
ultimately again it's your
responsibility to do your due diligence
and check this before you buy the house
number 10 this is one of my personal
favorites Japanese nut weed Japanese
knotweed
an absolute nuisance it's a pain it's
deadly it grows through concrete it
spreads it can literally pull down the
the foundations of your house and make
your house completely worthless now
Japanese knotweed you can't just pull it
out and put it in the dump in fact it's
illegal to take it to the skip because
it's so deadly we thought it looked
pretty the Brits brought it into this
country as a decoration plant not known
how deadly it was so if you have
Japanese knotweed in your garden if
you're looking at a house that has
Japanese Norwood am I saying that you
should not buy the house absolutely not
in fact it makes sense to buy properties
with problems as long as you know how to
fix the problem before you buy the house
so if you've got Japanese knotweed I've
bought properties of Japanese knotweed
but I've always had a professional to
come in and give me a quote to get rid
of the Japanese knotweed or ensure it
and put it under management that might
cost a few thousand pounds but make sure
if you suspect Japanese Norwood you get
a professional in to look at the
property so those are the 10 top things
that could make your property
unmortgageable if I've missed any if you
can think of any other problems with
properties that might make a house
unmortgageable please do comment below I
did a whole video on this called what
makes a good property investment I think
you'll really like the video check it
out right here also if you'd like to
find deals in a really good environment
and can become financially free in
property you need to come up the
property investors crash course you can
book them right here and don't forget to
subscribe to this Channel and you can do
that over here thanks so much I'll see
you next time don't forget to subscribe
[Music]